mark cuban is being sued for an
investment he calls as close to
risk-free as you're gonna get in crypto
right before it all crashed i'm not
trying here to tell you it's 100
risk-free but it's as close as close to
risk-free as you're going to get in the
crypto universe create an account using
the promotional called code mavs 100
well that didn't turn out so well it
turns out now you can use code sue the
mavs at checkout to recoup your money
now is this a sure thing no but it's as
close to a sure thing as you're going to
get in the world of suing billionaires
because fast forward several months
after the mavs jumped into this
investment opportunity the almost
risk-free company voyager declared
bankruptcy and froze everyone's money
more pain in the world of crypto voyager
digital files for chapter 11 bankruptcy
protection just days after the broker
suspended withdrawals on the platform
now i reported on this a few months ago
how voyager disguised itself as a
low-risk business and used misleading
marketing to make incredibly dumb
lending decisions that some people would
call doing a 2008. now because of that a
class action lawsuit has just been filed
against voyager and mark cuban it claims
that they both promoted a ponzi scheme
that cost a lot of people money so today
we're going to dive into this lawsuit to
figure out what's going on
so to begin the first thing you need to
know about this story is that this is
actually the second class action lawsuit
against voyager the first one happened
almost a year ago it's called the
cassidy lawsuit the main allegation in
this lawsuit is that it accuses voyager
of lying which i know is a bit like
accusing ezra miller of a felony it's
about as unsurprising as the sunrise but
plaintiffs accused voyager of lying
about claims of 100 commission free
trading voyager advertised that when you
buy bitcoin or ethereum there's no fees
to do so which obviously sounds very
attractive until you realize that
voyager makes millions of dollars in
fees despite having no fees so how is
that possible well they make money on
something called the spread this is the
difference in price of when you buy and
sell this is how a lot of free brokers
essentially work except in the case of
voyager they had told people that they
had a special technology saving them
even more money called the smart order
router according to their marketing it
identifies inefficiencies in the crypto
market which it then uses to quote get
you a better price on your trades which
all meant according to voyager they only
make money when you save money
unfortunately this wasn't true allegedly
voyager charges their users the highest
premium on trades across all competitors
and quote on all but one occasion
voyager's prices were worse than
whichever exchange they were compared to
so the only person this smart order
router was working for was really
voyager and in hindsight it's not
exactly surprising that voyager was
making money off trading fees but it's
how brazen they were about lying about
it that was the problem voyager
repeatedly advertised things like
getting you the quote most bitcoin for
your buck with images of voyager
checking multiple exchanges for pricing
but this is allegedly false and that's
what lawsuit one is about voyager lied
people died okay well people didn't die
people paid millions more than they had
to but then next came the bankruptcy of
voyager which we know a lot about their
lending team basically acted like
degenerates on wall street bets and lost
everyone's money on high-risk loans and
that all brings us up to today
lawsuit number two with our boy mark
cuban the lawsuit basically says hey
people lost millions maybe billions of
dollars because you said this was all
close to risk-free and it clearly wasn't
now the plaintiffs are suing to recoup
losses they claim are up to 5 billion
dollars which i know sounds like a lot
um i'm guessing this is so that they can
negotiate later and maybe get a fraction
of that in some kind of a settlement but
while there are a lot of things in this
lawsuit that are similar to the first
one there are a few new things worth
talking about firstly it came out in
discovery that cuban actually knew about
the first lawsuit the cassidy one and
apparently he even was worried about it
or wondered if he should be worried
about it allegedly he contacted the ceo
stephen ehrlich about it and clearly
never communicated any of that or the
risk to his fans and the other big thing
in this lawsuit is that it accuses cuban
and stephen erlick of running a ponzi
scheme where basically they were kept
bringing in new people to pay for the
other people until it all imploded now
i'll leave it to you guys to decide
whether this was all a ponzi scheme or
not but what i know is true is that
voyager definitely misled people all the
while claiming to be transparent
and looking out for the customer which
to me is about as bad as it gets and so
we're trying to make sure that we're so
transparent about this and transparency
is really
what what
leads us to being trying to build you
know
the next generation of financial
services company is by being transparent
about it i'm sure if like cred if it was
quarterly financials you know some of
the things that they're talking about
might have gotten caught earlier so we
it's important to us so yeah it turns
out they weren't transparent at all and
not only that they used one of the most
respected businessmen in the world to
push their misleading claims onto
millions this is especially ironic given
how cuban talks about how the goal of
this partnership is education and
financial literacy it's the education
that we want to bring to bring education
the education of education education
teach the youth about financial literacy
financial literacy financial literacy
financial literacy well i guess it is
fair to say that investors got an
education just probably not the one mark
cuban was talking about the whole irony
here is that cuban is always pushing the
same trash that he's ranting against
like on the one hand he'll call
metaverse real estate the dumbest ever
which to be fair might be true but then
on the other hand he turns around and
gets caught in scam after scam and at
some point you have to ask yourself when
does he become responsible for what he
says especially when he's one of the
most recognizable businessmen on the
planet thanks to shark tank i mean when
mark cuban speaks for better or worse
and he is a terrible crypto investor
people still listen so it's sad when he
says things like this there's a lot of
ways to inexpensively start to get an
understanding
and it's a lot easier than even opening
up a savings account it's a pain in the
ass to open up a savings account
particularly for your kids these days
there's so much paperwork and you know
whether it's yourself personally someone
you're trying to teach you're trying to
teach your kids about personal finance
believe it or not this is actually a
better way and so that's one of the
unique opportunities and why it's not
too late
that's right why fill out all that
boring paperwork at a bank when you can
lose all your money instead for a
valuable lesson in personal finance of
course i'm hoping that if the fans
actually win this lawsuit it's a lesson
in personal finance that mark cuban
won't forget either are you serious